moi j'aime bien ton profil moi tu vois
c'est
ah ouais là on dirait Las Vegas là
[Musique]
j'habite Cherbourg j'ai 42 ans je suis
marié avec Marcel j'ai 5 filles et ça
fait 13 ans que je fais du spectacle et
que j'ai mis Johnny Hallyday
j'ai commencé j'avais 11 ans et je
faisais des booms pour mes copains et
déjà on va peut-être venir
depuis je parcours la France entière
chaque week-end combien vous êtes payé
voir un spectacle comme ce soir ça
dépend ça dépend ça dépend des
spectacles
c'est une fourchette de prix qui les
sosies ont environ
[Musique]
mais pour moi c'est un plus par rapport
à mon salaire de l'ouvrier c'est pas
toujours évident de vivre avec un
salaire 8000 francs par mois à 7
récemment quoi je parle et donc de faire
des spectacles d'imiter d'une idée ça
permet de mieux vivre et d'avoir apporté
un plus à nos enfants et puis comme je
vous le ce soir on va vous mettre le feu
on va voir qu'à Montargis grasse à vous
surtout chers amis du public et bien ici
Montargis c'est similaire à Bercy à
Paris
et bien sans plus attendre pour vous ce
soir
[Musique]
pour moi quelqu'un que pour moi c'est un
modèle d'homme j'aurais aimé quelque
part me retrouver en lui c'est important
pour moi
ça m'aide à m'évader du personnage de
Denis qui est un personnage normal quoi
tout à fait normal
Patrice
tu vas bien
vous êtes une fan du vrai Johnny
Hallyday
vous l'avez vu en concert le vrai non je
n'ai pas les moyens alors je me
reproduis l'amour que j'ai pour Johnny
Hallyday sur Johnny
tout simplement demain vous auriez
l'argent oui pour voir le vrai nous
avons des Denis
pas du tout ah non parce que avec
Johnny on peut quand même côtoyer que le
Johnny Hallyday on peut pas le toucher
le pas lui causer le pas faire comme
avec Johnny et rock ça c'est sûr moi
j'ai reçu Johnny à Rock chez moi et tout
ça bon ben que je pourrais pas me
permettre d'inviter Johnny Hallyday chez
moi
voilà c'est tout Johnny rock c'est un
ami maintenant je suis entouré on a créé
le fan club avec mon épouse on a créé un
fan club et voilà quoi
quelque part aussi identifie à lui
avec nos moyens
[Applaudissements]
qui soit admiratif par rapport à ce que
je fais ça ça me fait plaisir mais de là
fan c'est vrai que c'est un petit peu
surprenant quoi c'est surprenant parce
que je ne suis rien moi c'est lui qui
est tout
[Musique]
angélique c'est ta chambre ici
c'est toi qui l'a entièrement décoré
comme ça mais ça te fait quoi d'avoir
tout ça
je me dis à la tête qui n'ont pas ce que
j'ai donc j'ai l'impression de posséder
un trésor toi
vous avez au concert toutes les deux ah
oui sûrement on va pas louper ça quel
est celle qui la plus accro à Jenny
je sais pas je crois que bon ben je
deviens aussi folle que ma fille tout
compte fait c'est ça vient même je crois
comment ça a changé votre vie depuis 4
ans de l'avoir rencontré Johnny rock
ben je sais pas moi ça nous fait plaisir
de le voir venir à la maison bon joie ma
fille elle a comment il lui a beaucoup
remonté le moral parce que bon au mois
de décembre elle avait perdu son père et
quand Johnny est venu à la maison elle a
pleuré dans ses bras et s'il consolait
sur Johnny rock ils l'ont emmené à
plusieurs reprises dans les galas pour
lui faire voir ce que c'était et moi je
trouve que de la part de Johnny c'est
c'est super parce que j'aurais jamais
pensé que ce serait intéressé à nous
et la première fois que je l'ai reçu à
la maison bon je me sentais un petit peu
gênée et tout parce que je disais bon
ben c'est quand même quelqu'un de plus
haut que nous et tout compte fait c'est
un homme qui est comme nous quoi
angélique j'ai l'impression d'avoir
découvert un autre univers avec lui un
univers plus grand quoi parce que bon un
univers de star en fait à peu près
tu es amoureuse de lui là au début
[Musique]
de foudre
j'avais très peur d'approcher quelqu'un
qui ressemble à mon idole
et si toujours
[Musique]
pas trop fatiguant de venir juste pour
le spectacle et repartir le lendemain
moi c'est pas grave c'est du moins que
c'est le rêve de ma fille on ferait
n'importe quoi
et bien moi j'aurais voulu réussir sur
mon propre nom de donner
c'est pas évident de se faire un nom et
faire quoi inventer quoi c'est pas
facile puisque Johnny a tout inventé
mais j'ai fait rêver les gens sur scène
donc en fait Denis le Maine c'est quand
même un artiste un petit artiste quelque
part
[Applaudissements]
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]